hey guys it's that time of the year
again and you need to get a special gift
for that special lady in your life but
you don't know what to get so in this
video I'm gonna give you ten good gift
ideas that you can get her and also a
bonus tip and then so let's get to it
[Music]
and just very quick if it's your first
time here on my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to DLM model lifestyle subscribe
can also click that notification about
so you won't miss any of the next videos
now let's start the first gift chocolate
every woman in the world loves chocolate
but don't just get her any chocolate get
her something special and unique like
chocolate from Godiva or real Belgium
chocolate I just remember I'll add the
links of all the gifts in a video
description down below so you can go and
check out book her for a nice massage
and she will love you for it because
every woman loves a good massage or you
can get her a foot massager so that she
can just go home and massage her feet
whenever she feels like it if she loves
long baths and get her a nice bath tub
tray with some special pampered goodies
like this one
perfume this gift will also benefit you
because you're gonna smell her the whole
time so get her something nice because
every woman loves good quality perfume
you can get her Calvin Klein euphoria
which is kind of sexy and heavy or you
can get her something fresh and feminine
like Dior I'll add a few extra options
for you in a video description that you
can check out if she doesn't have
wireless earbuds then it's a good idea
to get it for her and I mean who doesn't
like music right now she loves reading
get her
the waterproof Kindle paperwhite she'll
love it
handbags women and their handbags I
don't need to explain anything here to
you because you know women love their
handbags so if she needs a new one just
get her something nice like one of these
from Michael Kors
[Music]
if she loves working out and to track
her progress then get her a Fitbit watch
she love it but don't get her workout
clothes that's don't do that never ever
jewelry just like chocolates you cannot
go wrong with jewelry if money is no
issue then get hurt this 10k white gold
diamond necklace or if you have a very
low budget then you can get hurt this
sterling silver zirconia necklace or if
that's not her type then do a little bit
of research do a little bit of digging
and you'll find what she loves all right
grab the last one and I'm also gonna
give you a bonus tip at the end so
remember so the last one is a very cool
hairdryer chances are she uses one every
single day so when you have the chance
go and check out which one she uses and
if she needs an upgrade then get her a
cool funky hairdryer
like this cool super sonic hairdryer
from Dyson not just the bonus step when
you buy her the gift get some flowers
with it for an extra impact and then
also give it to her when she doesn't
expect it and she'll love it
Church guys